often thank you well we never get out in
front of a decision the president may or
may not make but
you just need look no further than the
history of the last
two and a half years when the u.s
sanctions were violated
we enforced them when the u.n sanctions
are violated
we're going to do everything we can to
enforce them as well
hi uh valera rebecca from ansa news
agency
uh mr secretary of state uh um when
like diplomats and others from some
countries say that
uh the process of the snapback is
difficult
and uh is difficult to uh to happen
what what does they mean uh they mean
because like
the u.s are not in the in the uh
uh deal anymore so do you think they do
you agree with that of course not but
why yeah so you you need you need to be
a little more precise and you should ask
them to be a little more precise
when you say they're not in the deal
anymore what do you mean
well the u.s like withdrawal from the
nuclear deal in 2018 yes yes yes
that's that's the position of the
country saying you know but i know that
you you
yes so so this this much this much is
accurate president may of 2018 made a
decision that we would no longer comply
with the political commitments
attached to the jcpoa but go read
paragraphs 10 through 12 of the 2231
they're completely separate
we provided no notice to the un right
when we withdrew
because it wouldn't have made any sense
to provide notice 2231 is completely
independent indeed
i thought it'd be worthy to take just a
moment to read you
what uh the state department the united
states state department told me
when i was a member of congress back in
2015. i asked this very question
i i knew i'd be here five years from now
i'm kidding
here's what they told me when i asked
this very question five years ago they
knew this day would come
here's what they said this is written
this is signed by
the assistant secretary of legislative
affairs at the state department dated
on november 19th of 2015 they said
everything this is that
the obamacare biden state department
they said the following they said
everything in the jco jcpoa and its
annexes are commitments
iran made and must keep to remain in
compliance
if iran breaks these commitments
the united states can snap back both
unilateral
and u.n sanctions
this look just it's important to
emphasize this 2231
gave every one of the participant states
the right to execute snapback
unconditionally there are other nations
that are not in compliance with the
jcpoa today
as well they would have the right to
conduct snapback as well
it is it's it's written it's plain it's
very straightforward i know the russians
and the chinese will try to obfuscate
they'll use their disinformation tactics
but just read the plain text of the
document it's not the case that a
political agreement
arranged by a group of parties including
the united states can undo
the amazing work of the un security
council no resolution can be altered
unilaterally by any country
not by iran not by russia not china nor
by the united states security council
resolutions
can only be changed by subsequent
security council
resolutions and so we think this is
really straightforward we think this is
very simple
uh these u and security council
resolutions will come back into place 31
days from now
and the united states will vigorously
enforce them
mr secretary is there anything that
would make you to change your mind to
actually
withdraw the request and what do you
think of the russia's proposal for
uh summit uh to convene and to actually
avoid the confrontation thank you
so there's no confrontation here so
there's no need to avoid any
confrontation this is straightforward uh
we stand here
at the united nations the u.n security
councils withstood lots of difficult
times this is easy
the security council resolution is very
plain very simple very straightforward
we know precisely how
it will proceed and so there's it's not
a matter for anger or frustration it's
just we'll follow the rules of the
un security council and that will lead
to the sanctions being reimposed
31 days from now as for things that
would cause us to change our mind it
would
if we could get to a place where we got
a full-on agreement with the islamic
republic of iran
to behave like a normal nation and live
up to the commitments we've asked for we
have been prepared to have that
conversation for a long time
were we able to achieve that we would
consider withdrawing this
i think it's unlikely in the 31 days
between here and there but
as a diplomat i always live in hope
thank you mr secretary do you think you
will have a different
support from what you had last week when
uh when your draft resolution was voted
on in the council
uh did any other members in the council
promise
to support your process and you
mentioned uh your european partners
maybe they say privately uh
different thank you thank you thanks for
doing this america we appreciate it yes
that's what they say
yeah uh what's your question do you
do you expect different support from the
council members
from yes we suspect we just we expect
every u.n member to comply with their
obligations under the security council
resolution we have
we have every confidence that when these
sanctions snap back that every nation
will execute them that that's your
obligation as a member of the united
nations to do that we have every
expectation that every
security council member will do that
thank you very much sir um
secretary of state um can you walk us is
less than two months from the
18th of october can you walk us through
the timeline where you think the
sanctions will be restored
on iran before october 18th
and if on the 19th of october you found
that
companies and banks from russia and
china are dealing with iran
regardless are you willing to sanction
them
so the answer to the second question is
we've been consistent throughout this
entire process
once president made the decision back in
may of 2018 we put u.s sanctions in
place
and we've done our level best to enforce
them we've been pretty effective i
remember some of the commentary maybe
from some of you
that said u.s sanctions alone won't be
successful
i would argue that today hezbollah is
much worse place
that the militias inside of iraq that
are run and controlled by the iranians
have fewer dollars
that iran has less capacity in syria
today all because
of the u.s sanctions and our enforcement
efforts so i think we've been enormously
successful
we will continue to enforce the
sanctions after uh
after these u.n security council
resolutions come back in place
uh we we've done it already we've
already gone after entities that
violated
the uh iranian sanctions regime doesn't
the country is immaterial
if they're in violation of these
sanctions we'll do our level best to
enforce them if our
it will become our obligation as a
member of the un in the same way it's
been our obligation
to enforce u.n u.s sanctions alone
it will come back within the next 31
days
one more
thank you so my question to you i just
want first to clarify something you said
about the fact that you
uh only draw uh out of the
gcp or eve politically can you explain
that please
and also isn't your own sanctions that
you imposed on iran
after uh 2018 may 2018
don't they go against the security
council resolution
two two three one because uh thank you
so so the agreement that that the
nuclear deal the
joint comprehensive plan of action the
jcpoa
is is wasn't a treaty wasn't ratified by
the united states senate or the
legislatures of other nations was just a
political agreement made
amongst the leaders the commitments that
each entered into
were mutual the the iranians are not in
compliance with the political
commitments that they made today
and you know president rouhani says that
the e3 is not in compliance either says
that they haven't lived up
says that the germans the french and the
united kingdom hasn't lived up
to their commitments under the jcpoa as
well they may well be
in non-compliance i suppose uh those are
a set of political agreements those are
far and separate and apart from
u.n security council resolution 22 31.
unique
u.n security council resolution 22-31 is
very plain
it says this set of states has the right
to execute
snapback there's not conditioned on any
other activity
it doesn't require compliance it just
says
these countries can execute snapback
it's very plain it's very simple
does it by the way the un is really good
at drafting documents when they want to
condition them
if it wanted to say you may execute
snapback if and only if
and place the condition it knows full
well how to do that it didn't choose to
do all here it didn't do it for a reason
it didn't do it for a reason it wanted
to make plain that
any nation that found that iran was not
in compliance
would have the capacity to do precisely
what it is the united states did today
that's what that's what we did we follow
the rules of u.n security council
resolution 2231 and we have
every expectation that the security
council will do its part
as well thank you all very much for
being with me have a good day
um
okay
foreign